bien alors ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que dans le dvd ya deux heures le
concert l'anglais l'aider mais à un
moment donné il ya 3 heures de dvd c'est
à dire c'est que ya eu les coulisses ya
les raretés il ya les duos il ya les
baises aussi à des moments
extraordinaires
on voit tout le monde est en train de
tirer des gonzesses dans la salle b les
volontaires ces magnifiques jean louis
c'est vraiment pris sur le vif
je dois dire il vient le dvd et les
biens des enfants mendient du bien voilà
et puis à le duo avec notre ami raphaël
une vraie passion il se rappelle vincent
aime bien me sordo qui ravage
ça me rappelle un peu le bouquin de la
morandais je n'étais pas une rencontre
avec dans un bar
pour faire plaisir à la baisse est assez
spirituel quand même voilà donc il a été
suspecté sécurité sinon chez les curés
non j'étais scout pas mal est fait et
topachat com ou toi parce que je veux
c'est la lose
monseigneur mon bâton soit mon père mon
père ils ont fait donc son père j'étais
scout aussi mais j'ai un foulard noir
j'étais scout libre j'ai pas d'aumônier
côté peut être scout 100 gr de cure pour
moi j'avais joué très libre oui oui mais
ça l'est un s'était pas c'était pas un
drame bien alors il ya danger dans dans
le dans le disque il ya une version de
vivant poèmes avec raphaël et on a
retrouvé la version originale de vivant
poèmes nom sur internet non ré et
barbare
évidemment
à
c'est pas qu'on l'avait ça non ces trois
là quoi voilà en fait barbare à elle
trouvé qu'il y avait un petit souffle
sur sa voix à la fin elle voulait leur
faire
ouais et elle est partie avant de leur
faire et ce qui n'est pas très
professionnel
alors jean louis vous êtes plutôt
idéaliste utopiste qu'opportuniste en
fait j'étais un enfant du rock et 68
finalement non c'est un enfant 68 c'est
sûrement vrai vivez comment la remise en
cause qui est fait aujourd'hui de 68
c'est dire la permissivité le laxisme
qui sont beaucoup critiqué comme un
héritage de 68 c'est vrai quand on est
parent on se retrouve un peu dans les
mêmes problèmes que nos parents elle mal
malgré tout c'est un mâle interdire des
trucs ne serait ce parce que
transgresser c'est bien agréable aussi
il faut bien avoir quelque chose à
transgresser sont les momies s'ennuie
ouais ils ont rien à transgresser
aujourd'hui - c'est bien d'avoir des
murs a fauté quoi 0 chez lui sautaient
desrochers repas le héros de oui c'est
moche il ya de plus en plus de rocher
fils
il ya des dégâts alors vous affirmez
souvent jean louis aubert être un homme
de 50 ans comme tout le monde vous dit
ça dans les interviews